ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE. WHILE WE
ARE NO LONGER SOCIALLY
DISTANCING IN THE HEARING ROOM
WE CONTINUE TO REQUIRE THAT
MASKS TO BE WORN IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE AMASSED WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. TO FACILITATE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC ACCESS
WITNESSES MAY TESTIFY BY PHONE
IN PERSON OR FROM THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED ON
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST. AND
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND OR DISTORTION. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN FOR COMING OUT OF
RETIREMENT AND STEPPING IN
TODAY TO FILL A VACANCY ON THE
COMMITTEE WELCOME BACK MR
BERMAN. AND WITH THAT WE CAN
NOW TURN TO THE BILLS BEFORE US
TODAY. PLEASE NOTE THAT SB
THREE FOUR SIX BY SENATOR WITH
COW SKI HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA SO WE ONLY BE
HEARING TO MEASURES STARTING
WITH S. B. TWENTY EIGHT. YEAH.
BEFORE WE GET IT WE INVITE
TRUMP CENTER COMING I JUST WANT
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM SORT ASK
THE CLERK TO CALL THE ROLL.
GABRIEL HERE APRIL PRESENT
KILEY OUR QUE HAN PARA QUE HAN
PRESENT BENNETT. BENNETT
PRESENT BERMAN BERMAN PRESIDENT
CORREA THEIR PRESENT CHAO CHAO
PRESENT CUNNINGHAM HERE
CUNNINGHAM PRESENT GALLAGHER
HERE GALLAGHER PRESIDENT
CAROLYN. WICKS WICKS PRESENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU DR
SECRETARY SENATOR COVER YOU'RE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
TWENTY OF TWENTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE CALIFORNIA
TWENTY ONE YEARS INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CAN CLOSE
OUR DIGITAL DIVIDE TO ENSURE
THAT LOW INCOME AND RURAL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO A
ROBUST DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
RIGHT THANK YOU I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY- SINCERE GRATITUDE
TO THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER THE THOUGHTFUL AND THE
CONSTRUCTED AT ANALYSIS AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WAYS TO
IMPROVE THE BILL'S HANDLING OF
DATA TO PROTECT CONSUMER
PRIVACY AND ITS APPROACH TO IT
TO A TEMPLATE AGREEMENT AND
WE'RE GOING TO COMMIT TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT THAT
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT- IF
WHERE IT PASSES OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT MEETS IT MEETS
THE- THE IN INTENT OF WHAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED- I'VE- I'VE GOT A
MOTION SO WONDER. IF YOU CALL
ME TO GO THROUGH ALL OF THIS- I
CAN I CAN MAKE THIS REALLY
SIMPLE I MEAN THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THE BILL. THE BILL THIS TOO
BIG THINGS ONE IS IT COMMITS UP
STATE RESOURCES. SUCH AS- UP
PROPERTY RESOURCES THAT STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM THAT- BUILDINGS
AND MAYBE THE FIBER THAT WE
HAVE LAID ALREADY. TO BE ABLE
TO BE UTILIZED IN A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WITH- WITH
ENTITIES- AND TO COME UP WITH
THE TEMPLATE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT EASY. TO AGREED TO USE THEM
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO IS IT
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
C. P. U. C. TO GET. DATA REAL
DATA ON EXACTLY WHERE WE'RE
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT ARE
THAT THEY REGULATE WHICH WHICH
IS A CABLE TV. AND ONCE WE GET
THAT INFORMATION IT TELLS US
SOME REALLY VALUABLE THINGS
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE PROVIDING
SERVICES A WORK OR NOT AND HOW
WE CAN USE OTHER FUNDS THAT WE
MAY HAVE. IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO DEPLOY DEPLOY THEM TO BE
ABLE TO CONNECT AND I KNOW YOU
ALL HAVE SEEN IN YOUR OWN
COMMUNITIES. THE LACK OF
SERVICES AND THAT'S WHY THIS
BECOMES A REALLY CRITICAL
ISSUE. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND TODAY HERE
WITH ME. IS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS JEFF NEAL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE SENATOR AND IS YOUR WITNESS
HEARING THE CHAMBER ON THE
PHONE I BELIEVE ON THE PHONE
ALL RIGHT SO- OPERATOR COULD WE
GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINE FOR JEFF NEAL. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JEFF NEAL HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY. REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
I'M REALLY PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY. OVER THE PHONE TO
SUPPORT SB TWENTY EIGHT AND
WANT TO THANK SENATOR CAPITO
FOR INTRODUCING IT- IT AND SHE
SAID THEM AND I WON'T. TAKE TOO
LONG HI THERE WILL REQUIRE THE
STATE TO IDENTIFY RESOURCES
STATE. IN BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT
THIS IS ONE OF THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE-
CALIFORNIA BROADBAND COUNCIL.
REPORT FROM A FEW MONTHS AGO
THAT WE AT SEATAC ADAM.
ENDORSES IN ITS ENTIRETY. M.
AND THEN THE OTHER PART OF THE
BILL- YOU KNOW JUST REALLY JUST
REQUIRES DIGITAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS TO LIVE UP TO THEIR
INDICATIVE. OF THE BARGAIN THAT
THEY FOUGHT SO HARD FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. IT JUST REQUIRES
THEM. TO LIVE UP TO THEIR END
OF DISCUSS THIS IS IN OUR VIEW
OF MUCH NEEDED AND OVERDUE
REFORM TOO. DIFFICULT THE
DIGITAL INSTRUCTION VIDEO
COMPETITION. ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SIX. IT'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BY AT THE TABLE SO
WE COULD THIS MEASURE- AND-
CHEER I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NONE WE WILL GO TO OUR- ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. SEEING NONE
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU MEDICARE- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO- WITNESS TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME A. T. T. OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE IT BACK
INTO THE QUEUE. SO AGAIN TO-
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH LINE EIGHTY
SIX. HI KAREN MEMBERS TIFFANY
MARC ON BEHALF OF CALDERON
PROFITS IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
OUR NEXT PERSON IS LINE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAMON
CONKLIN WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WHY NINETY YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
CHEN MEMBERS HERE ARE OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS BANOS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER KEVIN AGAIN SAID THAT
CARBON CREDIT ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
SHOULD BE USED IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS REPRESENTING FOOD
PROCESSING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. LINE NINETY SIX
EUROPE. WARNING THIS IS
VERONICA AVAILABLE SCREWS UP IN
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TOWARD ACTUAL PLAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ONE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. H. YES GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS SHARON MEMBERS ALONG
THE FENCE IN RECOMMENDING CAL
CALM AND I KIND OF DON'T FIT IN
THE SUPPORT BUT- WE ARE NEUTRAL
WITH THE AMENDMENTS ON JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH TAKEN AND THAT
COMMITTEE- SO I AM A TESTIFYING
AS NEUTRAL THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER I TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB TWO EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE WILL GO ONLINE SEVENTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING TURN
NUMBERS MY NAME IS MARINA THREE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA EDGE
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWENTY THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. DEAN REVERTS
WORLD CAUCUS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. WHY NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHANGAAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION AND THE SECOND
BALLOT COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT AS MEDICAL TWENTY EIGHT.
AND THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TWO EIGHT.
AND LINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE WILL TURN
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OUR
LEAD WITNESS IS CAROLYN
MCINTYRE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATIONS CAN YOU OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINE FOR MISS
MCINTYRE PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS CAROLYN MCINTYRE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE CONTINUE TO BE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY EIGHT
AND WE BELIEVE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
CLARIFY SOME OF THE ISSUES
RELATED TO DEATH CANNOT BUILD
OUT REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL HOWEVER
FOR PURPOSES I'VE LIVED
COMMITTEE- I'D LIKE TO FOCUS MY
TESTIMONY. ON SECTION TWELVE.
SB TWENTY EIGHT SECTION TWELVE
THE PAST PACIFIC PLATE WITH.
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
ALSO PROVIDE VIDEO FRANCHISE
SERVICE TO REPORT VERY SPECIFIC
TYPES OF BUSINESS PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. FIRST OF
ALL AS I INDICATED THAT THE
ONLY APPLIES TO ONE TYPE OF THE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER IN SO
IT IS NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AS
WE UNDERSTAND IT SENATORS AND
CAN'T BE INFORMATION IS TO BE
REPORTED IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
WHERE BROADBAND FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED IN THIS SERVICE. IS
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE. THE END.
THAT SECTION TWELVE WOULD BE
THE INDUSTRY TO REPORT HOWEVER
IS INCONSISTENT IMPART AND
DUPLICATIVE IN PART OF
INFORMATION THAT THE INDUSTRY
IS BEING REQUIRED TO REPORT TO
THE FEC PERSPECTIVE THE
BROADBAND DATA ACT FOR PURPOSES
OF BROADBAND MAPPING. WE HAVE
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS- AND FOR
THE SENATORS CONSIDERATION AND
AXAPTA COMMITTEE CONTENT
CONSIDERED THE SAME. TO AMEND
THE BILL TO ONLINE AND LYNETTE
THE REPORTING OF INFORMATION TO
THE C. P. U. C. TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THAT
INFORMATION THAT IS BEING
REPORTED TO THE SEC. PURSUANT
TO THE BROADBAND DATA ACTING
AND THAT THE REPORTING WHY TO
ALL INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
ALL FACILITIES BASED INTERNET
BROADBAND PROVIDERS EQUALLY-
WE'D ALSO LIKE CLARIFICATION
THAT ANY INFORMATION REPORTED
PURSUANT TO THIS SECTION WOULD
IN FACT. BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE ARE GOING TO TURN TO ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE MISTER OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION- FOR SB TO WAIT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY
ZERO TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
SB TWO EIGHT. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE NINETY TWO. I GOOD MORNING
AND THE G. CARE NUMBERS THE TWO
PM LIMITS WITH CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS- IN THE AD
CONTINUED OPPOSITION AT U. S.
B. TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. AND
AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR SB. TWO
EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND ALL
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW BREAK BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. SCOUTER
SENATOR- OBVIOUSLY- BOTH OF US
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND ENSURING THAT WE EXPAND-
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET-
IN OUR CONSTITUENCIES- TO THE
TO THE POINT OF THE OPPOSITION
THAT THIS IS KIND OF TARGETED
MORE TOWARDS THE VIDEO SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND DOESN'T
NECESSARILY INCLUDE YOU KNOW
ALL THESE OTHERS WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THE SAME. ISSUE YOU
KNOW TELECOMMUNICATIONS- I MEAN
WHERE YOU HAD SOME OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS IN TERMS OF MAY
MAKING AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE AND ALSO- KIND OF
MAKING IT SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
WAY THAT THEY REPORT TO THE
FEC. FCC WOULD BE- HOW THEY
WOULD REPORT TO THE PC. WE'RE
JUST GONNA JUMP IN FOR ONE
MOMENT- SENATORS SO- ALL ALL I
TO ANSWER IF YOU WANT JUST TO
JUST TO POINT OUT YOU KNOW WE
ARE WE HAVE A VERY NARROW SLICE
OF THIS BILL THAT'S WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND SO THOSE ISSUES WERE- YOU
KNOW DEBATED ROBUSTLY AND YOU
KNOW PRIOR COMMITTEE AND SO I
JUST WANNA GIVE YOU DON'T. YOU
SHOULD FEEL FREE TO RESPOND IF
YOU CAN BUT THE WHAT WE'RE
REALLY FOCUSING ON TODAY IS A
VERY STE NERO SLICE OF THIS
BILL IS A RESIDENT AT DEALS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY NOW TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT IS. FOR MY
PURPOSES AND OBVIOUSLY KAREN
ABOUT THE ISSUE AND HAVE AND
NOT HAVING BEEN IN THAT
COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO GET
SOME INFO. AT THAT NUMBER BOTH
THAT THE COMMON IN THAT THE-
THE ISSUE BOB LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THEIR REGULATION THERE
REGULATORY AUTHORITY AND THE
SEPARATION BETWEEN WHAT THE
STATE CAN REGULATE AND WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
REGULATE. THEY REGULATE THAT
THE INTERNET- AND- UNTIL THEY
MAKE THE DECISION THAT IT'S NOT
JUST AN ENTERTAINMENT- INTO-
REGULATORY PROCESS UNTIL THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A- IS
MUCH MUCH. MORE IMPORTANT TO
THE ECONOMY AND IT'S AT
COMMERCE ISSUE- WE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO REGULATE THOSE
ENTITIES THAT ARE JUST
PROVIDING INTERNET SERVICES
WHAT WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REGULATE. IS THE ART THE VIDEO-
THE VIDEO SERVICES AND SO- THE
REASON WE CAN GET INTO LOOKING
AT WHERE THE SERVICE IS BEEN
PROVIDED QUITE FRANKLY. IS THIS
PANDEMIC HAS AT SENDING US ALL
HOME AND THEN REQUIRING.
EDUCATION TO HAPPEN THROUGH THE
INTERNET REALLY. HIGHLIGHTED
THE FACT THAT OUR SERVICES ARE
NOT. EQUALLY. OR- RIGHT IN
EVERYTHING COMMUNITY AND OP
LIKE IT SHOULD BE SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ISSUES RELATED TO HOW
ARE WE GOING TO GET THERE- THAT
I WON'T GO INTO BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT WHAT WE CAN
REGULATE. IT IS THE VIDEO
SERVICES AND WE KNOW WHERE
THOSE ARE LOCATED- BASED ON THE
BUNDLING THAT'S BEEN DONE. WITH
WITH THE PACKAGES THAT ALSO
PROVIDE INTERNET INTERNET
SERVICES SO. WHAT PART OF THE
CHALLENGE WITH HOW. INFORMATION
IS REPORTED TO THE CPSC. IS
THAT IT'S DONE AS A SERVICE
AREA SO A COMPANY COMES IN THIS
IS I'M GONNA PROVIDE SERVICE TO
THIS AREA. I'M ON I DIDN'T
BRING MY MAPS BECAUSE THIS IS
THAT'S NOT THE SUBJECT AREA OF
THIS- COMMITTEE BUT I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO SHOW YOU. IF WE
WITH SOME REAL SPECIFIC DATA
WHAT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN.
WHAT THE- COMPANY SAY THEY'RE
PROVIDING IN A SERVICE AREA AND
THEN. WELL THE INFORMATION WHEN
YOU COMPARE IT TO WITH THE SEC
IS GETTING. ON ON IT LOOKS LIKE
SWISS SWISS CHEESE IS WHAT IT
AMOUNTS TO. THESE COMPANIES.
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING IN IT AS
PART OF THE P. C. P. C- HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE THEY
WERE GIVEN A VERY VALUABLE
FRANCHISE. AND THE FRANCHISE
TOOK AWAY THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO HAVE A SAY IN
HOW BAD VIDEO CONFERENCING
SERVICES IT WAS DEPLOYED I
REMEMBER BECAUSE I WAS ON THE
CITY COUNCIL THEY HAD TO
NEGOTIATE WITH US. AND AND
INSTEAD THEY GOT A STATE WIDE
FRANCHISE AND THE AGREEMENT
THEY MADE AT THE TIME WAS THEY
WOULDN'T DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T THEY
DON'T HAVE MONEY. AND SO THE C.
P. U. C. IS RENEWING THEIR
FRANCHISE AGREEMENT AND YET
THEY'RE THEY'RE BEING GIVEN
DATED THAT IS. NOT DOES NOT
GIVE THEM THE ABILITY TO KNOW
WHETHER THERE THERE'S
COMMUNITIES BE DISCRIMINATE OR
NOT. SO THIS BILL PUTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BACK AT THE TABLE
DURING THOSE THOSE REVIEWS OF
THE OF THE LICENSING. SO MUCH
AS I'D LIKE TO- REGULATE ALL OF
THE COMPANIES WE JUST DON'T
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY. CURRENT
LAW IN- IN TERMS OF FEDERAL
PREEMPTION SO YEAH AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT BY VIRTUE OF.
JUST THE WAY THINGS ARE AND THE
WAY THINGS ARE SET UP- ME ABOUT
TO THE STATE LEVEL AND FEDERAL
LEVEL- THE WAY THAT WE REGULATE
THINGS. I GUESS THE ISSUE IS
THAT. ALL THESE PLAYERS ARE
PART OF THE SOLUTION AND HAVE
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION. AND
IN FACT I MEAN NOW I MEAN IT I
THINK IT'S EVEN BEEN EXPANDED
YOU KNOW WITH THEM. YOU KNOW
THE- STARLIGHT TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT ON- NEARBY.
YOU KNOW I MUST COMPANY THAT HE
STARTED. IT MAY BE THAT WE YOU
KNOW THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY GET
HIGHER SPEEDS THERE IS AN
ARTICLE RECENTLY THAT- IN TAMA
COUNTY WHICH I REPRESENT- THIS
IS BEEN SHOWN TO INCREASE
INTERNET SPEEDS BY OVER 510050%
AT WHICH WOULD BE HUGE RIGHT
AND SO MAYBE IT'S NOT A FIBER
OPTION YOU KNOW A LOT OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE. THERE IN THE
FIBER WORLD RIGHT. AND YEAH BUT
YOU TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND NEW
TO AND WIRELESS AND OTHER.
ENTITIES THAT ARE REALLY PART
OF THIS I FEEL LIKE IT'S KIND
OF. WE'RE ONLY FOCUSING ON ONE
PART WHEN THERE'S A BIGGER
PICTURE HERE YOU KNOW SO THAT'S
WHY. ONE OF MY CONCERNS I GUESS
GOING FORWARD AND FIGURE OUT
HOW DO WE CRACKED THAT NUT IF
YOU WILL- UNDERSTOOD- AND THEN
ONE OTHER ISSUES FROM THE
LOCALS WHICH IS YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THIS IS ADDITIONAL COST
IN THE WAY THAT FRANCHISE FEES
WORK IS THIS COULD GET COME
INTO JUST THE OVERALL
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS INCREASES
IN THEIR ONLY OBLIGATED TO GIVE
SO MUCH. IT COULD IMPACT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY REVENUE THAT
GOES BACK TO. HIS PC TAKES A
CHUNK OFF THE TOP OF THAT.
RIGHT IF THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE
MORE BECAUSE OF THIS YOU KNOW.
THE PROVISIONS THIS BILL IS
THAT LESS MONEY THAT'S GOING TO
GO BACK TO. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
I DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
ANY ISSUE OF REACHING FINANCIAL
RESOURCES THAT. THAT EITHER
CHANGED IN THIS BILL OR THAT
ARE. PROPOSED TO BE CHANGE IN
THIS BILL OKAY. THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
JUST MAKE A COMMENT THAT I JUST
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF
TRYING TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN I
REALIZED IT TOOK SOME
CREATIVITY AND DEAL WITH THE
LEGAL CHALLENGES EXETER- BUT-
WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THERE'S
A REAL NEED SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR FOR. PUSHING THANK
YOU SIR APPRECIATE THAT. ALL
RIGHT SEE NOTE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I WANT
TO. JUST CLARIFY WITH THE
AUTHOR JUST TO MAKE SURE CLEAR
YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE- THE- MMS
IN THE ANALYSIS IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THE BALLOT FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THE AMENDMENTS- IN APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE
THIS IS A- CRITICAL ISSUE THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHICH HAS ONLY
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHICH YOU AND I
DISCUSSED. AND WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS ONE OF MANY BROADBAND
BILLS THAT ARE MOVING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK YOUR BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THAT BROADER
CONVERSATION. YOU KNOW OUR
COMMITTEE TODAY'S CONSIDERING
ONLY A VERY NARROW PART OF YOUR
BILL- THE FALLS UNDER THE
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC JURISDICTION
OF THE COMMITTEE. AND ON THOSE
ISSUES I BE I STRONGLY AGREE
WITH YOU THAT THE EXPERTISE AND
RESOURCES OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY SHOULD
BE LEVERAGED TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. AND WITH THAT I'M I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING A FORD.
AND DIED YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU AND IT JUST KNOW THAT I
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO TRY TO GET IT RIGHT
AND I THINK THE SECTION THAT
WAS- CALLED OUT IS A SECTION
THAT DEALS WITH THE ISSUES THAT
THE COMMITTEE WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT WE'VE AGREED TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE WE HAD A MOTION AND A
SECOND- MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS SB
TWENTY EIGHT THE OTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GABRIEL HI
GABRIEL I KILEY KILEY I PARA
QUE HAN R. K. HAND I'VE BEEN
IT'S BEEN A AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
I CARILLO. I HAD CHAO CHAO I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER HI
EVERYONE. IRWIN HIGHWAY SIX
WEEKS HI. THAT BILL IS ABOUT.
REGULATION SENATOR YOUR BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NOW
MOVE TO OUR FINAL BILL SB FORTY
ONE WELCOME SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU THIS YEAR THAT I HEAR
MOST OF THE SECOND I HAVE ALL
RIGHT. WELL AS A AN EXPERIENCED
TRIAL LAWYER I KNOW NOT TO
ARGUE WITH THE JUDGE IF. I
THINK THE JUDGE IS GOING MY WAY
SELL- I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE I
DO HAVE WITNESSES SO- AND I
WANT TO THANK LANDED KLEIN-
COMMITTEE STAFFER FOR WORKING
SO HARD ON THIS BILL- I'VE
MAUREEN MAHONEY WITH CONSUMER
REPORTS AND RICHIE INGLE HEART
FROM ANCESTRY. ANCESTRY .COM.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR
BREVITY. WE ARE GOING TO GO
AHEAD I BELIEVE THAT- THAT- IS
THAT MR WORKING HARD HERE IN
PERSON IN THE IN THE ROOM. TO
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SIR
GABRIEL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME SEARCHING A
HEART ON THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS WITH
ANCESTRY. ANCESTRY IS THE
WORLD'S LEADING FAMILY HISTORY
COMPANY AND ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROVIDERS OF DIRECT TO CONSUMER
GENETIC TESTING SERVICES. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB FORTY ONE.
WE'RE PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE WITH OUR COALITION
PARTNERS INCLUDING TWENTY THREE
AND ME TO IMPLEMENT COMMONSENSE
PRIVACY ROTECTIONS THAT ENSURE
THEIR GENETIC
TIMES. TOGETHER WITH PRIVACY
ADVOCATES IN THE FUTURE OF
PRIVACY FORUM A LEADING NON
PROFIT. PROFIT THAT FOCUSES ON
PRIVACY THOUGHT LEADERSHIP. OUR
COALITION DEVELOPED WHAT WE
BELIEVE ARE THE APPROPRIATE
GUIDELINES TO ENSURE CONSUMERS
HAVE CONTROL OVER THEIR DATA.
ARE PRESENTED WITH EASY TO
UNDERSTAND PRIVACY POLICIES ARE
EMPOWERED TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
HOW THEIR DATA SHOULD BE USED
INCLUDING A REQUIREMENT THAT
THEY PROVIDE EXPRESS CONSENT.
ANY TIME THEIR DATA IS SHARED
WITH A THIRD PARTY. AND CAN AND
THEIR RELATIONSHIP AND DELETE
THEIR DATA AT ANY TIME. SB
FORTY ONE PUT THESE PROTECTIONS
INTO LAW OUTLINING OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AND CLEARLY
EXPLAINING THEIR RIGHTS WHEN
THEY ENGAGE WITH DTC GENETIC
TESTING SERVICES TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THEIR GENEALOGY OR
HEALTH. SB FORTY ONE WILL ALSO
ENSURE THAT EVERY DIRECT TO
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING
SERVICE IS HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE SET FOR
PRIVACY AND DATA PROTECTION. IF
PASSED CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE THE
STRONGEST PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
FOR GENETIC DATA IN THE WORLD.
WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR UMBERG
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF GENETIC
PRIVACY AS WELL AS OUR
COLLEAGUES AT CONSUMER REPORTS.
AND THIS COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL OF THE WORK UNDERTAKEN SO
FAR ON THE BILL. AND I WELCOME
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER HART-
WE'RE NOW GONNA. GO TO OUR
SECOND WITNESS IN SUPPORT- ON
THE PHONE THAT WILL BE MARIE
MAHONEY FROM CONSUMER REPORTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AT
CONSUMER REPORTS OR PROBABLY
SUPPORTING SB FORTY ONE BECAUSE
OF PROVIDE IMPORTANT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. FOR UNIQUELY SENSE
OF GENETIC DATA THE DATA CAN
PROVIDE INSIGHTS INTO WHETHER
YOU OR A FAMILY MEMBER IS
VULNERABLE TO CERTAIN DISEASES.
AND CONSUMERS FROM THE VALUE
PROTECTIONS OVER THE STATE-
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND CONSUMERS
HAVE SIGNED A PETITION CALLING
ON LAWMAKERS TO ENSURE THAT
THIS DATA. IS KEPT PRIVATE AND
SECURE THE BORDER CHOIRS
CONSENT TO THE COLLECTION
SECONDARY USE AND DISCLOSURE OF
THIS DATA HAS A PROVISION TO
REVOKE CONSENT AS WELL PUTTING
CONSUMERS SQUARELY IN CONTROL.
WHEN WE HAVE A STRONG
DEFINITION OF CONSENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT CONSUMERS KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING INTO NEVER REAL
CHOICE OVER HOW THEIR DATA IS
USED. ALREADY STATES LIKE
ILLINOIS AND MISSOURI HAVE
ROBUST PROTECTIONS OF THE STATE
AT THIS TIME THE CALIFORNIANS
HAVE STRONG PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AS. WELL AS YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE
NOW GOING TO TURN TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NINE DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. SEEING NOT
MISTER OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
AYE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE LINE IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B. FOUR
ONE. WE'LL BEGIN WITH THOUGHT
LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIRST PENSIONS OF CORBIN AND
KINDER ON BEHALF OF PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE. AND
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ADELINE
EIGHTY YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS TERRIBLE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FOUR ONE. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN. HI I'M GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER IF YOU ON YOUR OWN
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER COLONEL AT THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AT THIS TIME WE WILL TURN TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
IS CAMA DIMITRI FROM
TECHCONNECT WHO WILL BE
APPEARING BY PHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS WHEN IT
CAME TO BE TRIMMED EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS
SOUTHWEST THE TECHNO. TECHNO
THE NATIONAL BIPARTISAN NETWORK
OF TECHNOLOGY CEOS AND SENIOR
EXECUTIVES THAT PROMOTES THE
GROWTH THE INNOVATION ECONOMY.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. SB FORTY ONE
INNER SEEKING TO AMENDMENTS AN
EXCEPTION SECTION OF THE
LANGUAGE. WELL WE UNDERSTAND
THE GOAL DOCTORS TO PLACE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS AROUND
DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING DATA. GIVE A COUPLE OF
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS. THE
LATEST AMENDMENT STILL IN STILL
BE NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUE WE
HAVE RAISED PREVIOUSLY WHICH IS
THAT GENETIC DATA AS DEFINED IS
TO BROADEN THAT INCLUDES ANY
DATA DERIVED FROM RESULTS.
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE SEEKING TO
ADD OR CONDITION AN EXCEPTION
SIX. DEFINITION IN CONJUNCTION
WITH HOW BROADLY A DIRECT TO
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING DATA
COMPANY IS ALSO DEFINED. IN THE
EVEN A CASUAL CONVERSATION THE
WORKPLACE RESULTING FROM THE
TAX MONEY TAKEN OR ANY GENETIC
PASSED WILL BE IN THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL. IT'S CERTAINLY
HELPFUL THAT THERE IS NO
EXCLUSION. DISEASE IN THE LATE
AMENDMENT BUTTON DEFINITION OF
GENETIC DATA INCLUDES DATA
RESULTING FROM. IT GOES BEYOND
JUST THE PAST. GARCIA SECOND
AMENDMENT HERE'S SOME SINNERS
WHICH ELIMINATE WHY WE'RE
SEEKING THE EXCEPTION OF ANY TO
WORKPLACE SAFETY. AMPLE ONE
EMPLOYER DECIDE THAT ALWAYS
NEED TO HAVE A NEGATIVE COVER
TEST RESULT TO CERTAIN
CUSTOMERS IN PERSON COVERED HAS
RELY ON GENETIC DATA IN MIGHT
RELY ON THE PRESENCE OR ABSENCE
CERTAIN PROTEINS OR OTHER
MARKERS OF COVERAGE. RATHER
THAN THE PRESENCE OR ABSENCE OF
THE VIRUS ITSELF. IT'LL TO
EMPLOYER DECIDES TO ALLOW
EMPLOYEES TO OPT INTO SPECIAL
WORK ARRANGEMENTS I HI THE
LOCATIONS AT THE MEASURE.
THURMOND COMPROMISED UNABLE TO
GET VACCINATED OR TAKE
MEDICATION INTERFERES WITH
THEIR ABILITY TO BUILD
COMMUNITY SOME OF THESE
EMPLOYEES MIGHT OPT AND BASED
ON TEST RESULTS FROM BLOOD OR
OTHER GENETIC DATA. PERHAPS
IMPORTER WOULDN'T KNOW THE
UNDERLYING REASON. BUT HOW
WOULD THIS BILL LOOKS WOULD
OFTEN DATA COLLECTED BY THE
EMPLOYER. THE LAST EXAMPLE THE
CDC DETERMINES THAT PREFIX
VACCINATIONS NOT ENOUGH TO STOP
THE SPREAD OF COVETING REQUIRES
ANYBODY TESTING. OR NEGATIVE
CODE ATTACHED AS WELL AS THE
FOUR EMPLOYEES CAN GATHER IN
GROUPS IS THE DON'T COVER
FUTURE POSSIBILITIES EXPENSE.
YOU FURTHER HOUSE HAS ISSUED
NEW GUIDANCE WHICH STRESSES THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENABLING
EMPLOYERS TO BE ABLE TO USE.
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION. NAY
RAISES CONCERNS WITH YOUR STAFF
REPORTER CONVERSATIONS AGAIN WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW TURN TO
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION. SEE
NON LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONES. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR SB FOUR
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHEN
FILED BY ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO AT THIS
POINT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS IN A MISTER
CUNNINGHAM WAS EAGER TO ASK A
QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND THIS QUESTION CAN BE
ANSWERED BY THE SENATOR OR- OR
ONE OF THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ACTUALLY TWO QUESTIONS- SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I THINK IT'S GREAT
BILL NEXT TIME WE DID IT. WE
NEEDED IT FOR A LONG TIME- MY
FIRST QUESTION MORE OF THE
BASIC LEGAL QUESTION THAT I
DIDN'T SEE ANSWERED IN AND ALSO
IS. THE SAY I TAKE A GENETIC
TESTS AND I SEND IT TO ANCESTRY
.COM TWENTY THREE IN ME OR SOME
OTHER. PROVIDER WHO WHO OWNS
THE ROAD TEST RESULTS
THEMSELVES LIKE WHO HAS TITLE
TO THAT. I'VE JUST ALWAYS
WONDERED THAT I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWERS CURIOUS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION EITHER
PERHAPS- IF THERE IS A- ONE OF
THE WITNESSES ON MIGHT BE ABLE
TO RESPOND THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
SO LET ME ASK. MR ENGELHARDT IF
HE KNOWS THE ANSWER IF NOT WE
CAN GET IT TOO. YEAH ABSOLUTELY
SO THERE THERE'S NO TITLING
PROCESS FOR GENETIC DATA- SO IT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO A QUESTION
OF WHO'S IN CONTROL OF THAT
INFORMATION. AND EVERY STEP IN
THE PROCESS THE CONSUMER HAS
CONTROL IF THEY WANT TO DELETE
THEIR DATA DESTROY THEIR
BIOLOGICAL SAMPLE THEY CAN
REQUEST THAT AND WE COMMIT IN
WRITING TO DO THAT WITHIN A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF DAYS. AND WE
DON'T USE THEIR DATA FOR ANY
PURPOSE THAT WE HAVEN'T
DISCLOSED UP FRONT OR THAT THEY
HAVE NOT PROVIDED SEPARATE
EXPRESS CONSENT FOR SO. WHILE
WE MAY HAVE THEIR DATA AND USE
IT FOR PRODUCT IMPROVEMENT AND
TO FIGURE OUT. YOU KNOW WHAT
GENES ARE AFFILIATED WITH
CERTAIN ETHNICITIES OR WHAT NOT
TO PROVIDE MORE ACCURATE
ETHNICITY ESTIMATES. AT ALL
TIMES THEY CAN TAKE THAT DATA
OUT OF OUR SYSTEM CLOSE THEIR
ACCOUNT HAVE EVERYTHING DELETED
THEY'RE IN CONTROL. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANSWER THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL MY SECOND QUESTION IS-
UNDER THIS BILL LET'S SAY I
TAKE A TEST AND- IT COMES BACK
IN THAT AND IT'S AND I DON'T
HAVE BEEN DELETED AND YOUR FIRM
ANOTHER FIRM HAS CUSTODY OF IT.
CONTROL OF IT- AND THEN I WANT
IT CONVEYED AT SOME POINT TO
THE SAID DR BECAUSE I'M WORRIED
I MAY HAVE PRECURSORS TO
PARTICULAR TYPE OF- ILLNESS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT I'D LIKE TO
HAVE IT. TESTED MEDICALLY TO
FIND THAT OUT IS THERE IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT EITHER PROHIBITS
OR AUTHORIZES OR ALLOWS THAT
TYPE OF. SUBSEQUENT CONVEYANCE
UNDER UNDER THIS BILL. SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST TO CLARIFY
YOUR QUESTION SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
I WANT. SAY ANCESTRY TO
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY WITH THE
PHYSICIAN IS OUR MECHANISM TO
DO THAT THAT YOUR QUESTION YEAH
OURS ARE PROHIBITED FROM FOR
ILLNESS IT UNDER I DON'T
BELIEVE IS PROHIBITED BUT MR
ANGLE HEARTS GOING TO CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG. NO I AM HAPPY
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION SO
EITHER INSISTING OR TWENTY
THREE AND ME HAVE A PROCESS TO
DIRECTLY COMMUNICATE A
CONSUMERS GENETIC DATA TO A
THIRD PARTY LIKE A PHYSICIAN-
IF A CONSUMER WANTED TO DO THAT
WHAT WE WOULD SUGGEST IS THAT
THEY EITHER PRINT THE REPORTS
OFF OF THE WEBSITE AND TAKE
THOSE TO THEIR PHYSICIAN OR
EMAIL THOSE TO THEIR PHYSICIAN.
OR THEY CAN DOWNLOAD THEIR
RAJIN ADDICT DATA THEMSELVES
AND TRANSMIT THAT OVER TO THE
PHYSICIAN NOW WE PROVIDE MANY
WARNINGS ABOUT DOWNLOADING YOUR
DATA BECAUSE ONCE IT'S OFF OUR
SYSTEM. WE CAN'T PROTECT HOW
IT'S TREATED ON YOUR LAPTOP OR
ON EMAIL OR WHATNOT FROM FROM
ANY OTHER INTERFERENCE BUT THEY
DO HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT
THEMSELVES WE DO NOT DIRECTLY
TRANSMIT THAT DATA TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SO. OKAY THE-
THAT SAYS. MY CONCERN THERE AND
I THINK THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE THE-
CUSTOMER USE OR WHATEVER YOU
CALL IT IS IN CONTROL OF THAT
AND THEN CAN TAKE IT APPARENTLY
TO A DOCTOR AND I THINK THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL UTILITY
FOR. PEOPLE IN THE HEALTH CARE
FOR THAT BEING ABLE FOR THAT
BEING A LOT. AND AS LONG AS
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE THAT'S-
GETTING IN THE WAY OF IT THAT
SOUNDS LIKE. A PROBLEMS- NOT A
PROBLEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M
GLAD WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT YOUR
SUPPORT. SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE VOTE
FORWARD UP ONE QUESTION AND A
COMMENT- SO DOES THIS IS
APPLIED RETROACTIVELY TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE. ALREADY TAKEN THESE
TESTS ARE JUST MOVING FORWARD
OR BOTH IT. IT IS PROSPECTIVE
OKAY- I LOVE THIS BILL AND I DO
TWENTY THREE ME AND I'M SORT OF
PSEUDO OBSESSED WITH ALL THIS
KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU GET WHEN
YOU- DO THESE TESTS SOME OF IT
IS INTERESTING AND HELPFUL SOME
OF IT'S A LITTLE RANDOM BUT- I
THINK IT'S VERY FASCINATING I'M
REALLY GLAD YOU'RE DOING IT. I
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THIS DATA IN PARTICULAR IS
PROTECTED WITH THE UTMOST. OF
PRIVACY CONCERNS OF THANK YOU
FOR DOING THE BILL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS. ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY WELL SEEING
NONE THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
BRING FOR THIS THIS IMPORTANT
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR PERSON
YOUR PERSISTENCE AND WORKING ON
THIS ISSUEOVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS- I THINK IT'S HARD TO
THINK OF ANYTHING THAT'S MORE
PERSONAL OR MORE REVEALING THAT
OUR GENETIC INFORMATION AND
THAT'S LIKELY TO BE EVEN MORE
SO AS SCIENCE PROGRESSES IN
OUR- UNDERSTANDING OF HUMAN
GENETICS INCREASES AND SO. WITH
THE PROLIFERATION OF THESE
DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING COMPANIES IT'S CRITICAL
THAT CONSUMERS ARE PROVIDED
WITH APPROPRIATE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS AND WE SURE THAT
SUCH SENSITIVE INFORMATION IS
PROTECTED FROM UNWANTED USES
AND DISCLOSURES. AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE GIVEN THE
CURRENT LIMITATIONS ON MEDICAL
PRIVACY LAWS OUTSIDE OF THE
HEALTH CARE CONTEXT I WANT TO.
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF TO CRAFT AN
AMENDMENT- THAT ADDRESSES THE
CONCERNS RELATED TO COVER
NINETEEN TESTING THAT WERE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S. VETO MESSAGE
LAST YEAR I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT AND WITH
THE PROTECTIONS THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE- CALIFORNIANS WHO DO
DECIDE TO ENGAGE IN DIRECT TO
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING CAN BE
FAR MORE CONFIDENT THAT THEIR
GENETIC DATA WILL BE TREATED
WITH THE CARE AND SENSITIVITY.
TO PRIVACY THAT THAT
INFORMATION DESERVES AND SO I'M
VERY PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY HE
RECALLS A BIG FAN OF A OF THE
VERSION LAST TIME. APPRECIATE
YOUR HARD WORK AND THAT WOULD
INVITE YOU TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THANK
YOU STAFF FOR WORKING ON THIS
AS WELL AS BEEN A SURPRISING
JOURNEY FROM WHEN WE FIRST
DISCOVERED THAT THERE WERE.
ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO. THE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AND YOUR
DNA- LOT OF SURPRISES I WAS
SURPRISED TO FIND OUT THAT I
HAVE A HIGHER THAN. AVERAGE
PERCENTILE IT'S A PERCENTAGE OF
NEANDERTHAL MY SPOUSE WASN'T
SURPRISED. BUT IF YOU IF YOU
LOOK INTO. THIS AREA YOU'LL SEE
THAT I THINK. THAT UP A NUMBER
OF BUSINESSES NUMBER OF-
DISTANCE IN THE INDUSTRY HAVE
BEEN. VERY CONSCIENTIOUS AND I
APPRECIATE THEIR SUPPORT
CRAFTING A BILL THAT I THINK.
ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS OF BOTH
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS THOSE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT PRIVACY-
GINGIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I THINK WE HAD A IN
IMMEDIATE MOTION AND A SECOND
SO AT THIS POINT MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SB FORTY ONE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I
KILEY. KILEY AYE PARA QUE HAN.
OKAY I'VE DONE IT HI BENNETT HI
BERMAN. BERMAN I CARILLO. CHAO
CHAO I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I-
WENT IRWIN AYE WE X. WICKS HI
THAT. SO I THINK WE ARE WE-
THANK. REALLY ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU CAN GO SENATOR THAT IS OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR-
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON- WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
WRAP UP OUR FINAL HEARING OF
THE YEAR AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE TO THANK OUR OUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR EXCELLENT
WORK- AND ALL OF THE STAFF WHO
MADE THIS POSSIBLE AND WE
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION AND- WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU NEXT YEAR.
SO BUT THE.